if you uh
let's play a fun experiment if you ran
let's do a tesla and let's do waymo
if uh elon musk took a vacation for
a year he just said screw it i'm gonna
go live on an island
no electronics and the board decides
that we need to find somebody to run the
company
and they they decide that you should run
the company for a year
how do you run tesla differently i
wouldn't change much
do you think they're on the right track
i wouldn't change i mean i'd have some
minor changes but even even my debate
with tesla
about you know end to end versus segnets
like that's just software who cares
right
like it's not gonna it's not like you're
doing something terrible with segments
you're probably building something
that's at least gonna help you debug the
end-to-end system a lot
right it's very easy to transition from
what they have
to like an end-to-end kind of thing
and then i presume you would uh
in the model y or maybe in the model 3
start adding driver sensing with
infrared yes i would add i would
i would add infrared camera infrared
lights
right away to those cars um
and start collecting their data and do
all that kind of stuff yeah
very much i think they're already kind
of doing it it's it's an incredibly
minor change if i actually were ceo of
tesla first off i'd be horrified that i
wouldn't be able to do a good job as
elon
and then i would try to you know
understand the way he's done things
before he would also have to take over
his twitter
so god i don't tweet yeah what's your
twitter situation why why
why are you so quiet on twitter comma is
like what what's your social network
presence like because you you
on instagram you're you're you uh you do
live streams you're
you're you're um you understand the
music of the internet
but you don't always fully engage into
it you're part-time i used to have a
twitter
yeah i mean it's the instagram is a
pretty place
instagram is a beautiful place it
glorifies beauty i like i like
instagram's values as a network
um twitter glorifies conflict glorifies
you know
like like like like like you know just
shots
taking shots at people and it's like you
know well
you know twitter and donald trump are
perfectly
tesla's on the right track in your view
yeah
you